what's with the jeans Tom I can't hear
anything in bed ex Fed Ex the next this
is what I hear no you don't hear that
you're making that up
only a retarded person would be like
FedEx and a retarded person saying FedEx
would make a lot more money on tour you
know why are you trying to make me
retarded it's so just do one tour as
retarded Tom and one is normal time and
just see what the difference in ticket
sales are well you know I have new
agents that's the time to bring them new
idea yeah sounds like I'd like to do a
retarded theater tour guys here's the
thing I know you're thinking of booking
me out as this not retarded standup
what I'm saying is let's let's revisit
the game maybe I am retarded you know
I'm saying and see if a retarded comic
you know I'm saying could bring in more
ticket sales you feel me you know I'm
talking about you know I'm saying you
know I'm coming what do you think they
would say they'd be like absolutely mr.
Sikora absolutely they want a commission
and you're gonna make so much money as
Tom Segura hearted comedian but you're
gonna make something like what I'll need
to do then is establish that I'm retard
like people that are coming in the shows
now know me as a not retarded guy so I
don't have to get a new persona I mean a
new name right no I think it's just the
evolution you know evolution it's like
that I'm retarded yeah you know like
Louie CK his children got older he
talked about that he got a divorce he
talked about that's right this is just
your evolution as a comedian how did I
become retarded it was natural it's not
natural you woke up what they retarded
so just walk out on stage oh yeah it's
fine
people just let Twitter let people on
Twitter tell you oh good that's where
I'd like to take my cues but that's what
our people tell you how to do it we'll
see let's see guys do you want to hear
Tom Segura retarded comedian just tweet
at him let him know that's how I'm
cigarette thanks babe
then you can form bigger than me
challenge he's throwing down the
gauntlet